what's the role of intelligence in all
of this FBI CIA the Chinese intelligence
agencies right now Mexico is going
through uh
a nationalistic Resurgence and leftist
presidency
which is not friendly to U.S interest in
a lot of ways
the U.S has had a pretty bad track
record when it's with its foreign policy
in Mexico with a lot of damage being
done by the last president as far as his
rhetoric uh Donald Trump which has been
weaponized and utilized by the the left
down down in Mexico
so America has not seen uh positively no
every now and then I post something
about Mexico some horrible thing
happening down there it's like why
doesn't us send people down there like
are Mexicans looking for like U.S
intervention it's like no
that is beyond what anybody in Mexico
would want us specifically you see the
sentiment out there
they don't view the us as a as somebody
that's going to come in and fix anything
or somebody that's going to help or as a
friend uh with the when the Ukrainian
conflict happened
uh Mexico basically is abstained from
saying anything
which is a winking or not to Russia it
has openly been pro-madural and openly
celebrated some of these uh regimes be
popping up uh across Latin America
you know which is
that is what people voted for that is a
sentiment down there they're going
towards the left of the political
spectrum because if they've been
basically violated over and over again
by all these different presidencies that
have promised changed brought corruption
with them and they are our choices so
this is this is the best we have right
now uh and all of the enemies of the
United States are taking full advantage
of that you know we recently had a
general kind of address a senate
committee hearing I think he was talking
about the prevalence of foreign
intelligence services in Mexico you know
and why that is
well you know it has Mexico has a lot of
the Mind of a lithium on the planet
underneath the parts of it specifically
in the North
at uh it is going through a process they
call it the La Cuarta transformation on
the fourth the fourth transformation is
what the president of Mexico calls it
which is uh in a way it's basically
we're here to stay type thing
you know they just uh nationalized
mining lithium and taking control of
that and using that as leverage if the
United States ever wants to go to Mexico
it's probably not going to be related to
cartel issues it's going to probably
relate to energy I think you know other
kind of thinking ahead I guess well what
about also just imagine a world
where India and China are doing fentanyl
trade with Mexico or whatever transport
imagine Chinese military moves makes an
agreement a NATO type of agreement with
Mexico that's pretty possible again
we're seeing a militarized Mexico it's
another aspect of Mexico that again I
haven't seen talked about a lot here in
the U.S
the main problem is that the current
president had was he was going to make
the police the federal police and the
the the the security issues in Mexico
civil civilian he was gonna do exactly
the opposite as his main rival Felipe
Calderon the guy that started off the
drug war officially
and what does he do he dissolves the
civilian leadership of the federal
police dissolves the federal police
creates the National Guard which is a
military unit and he puts the military
in charge of that
now the military has a full Monopoly
overall Federal policing there when you
cross into Mexico you'll see them
wearing these white camouflage uniforms
those are
those are National Guard people but
they're they're they're they're the
military so now you're seeing a military
rise in Mexico with some of these leaks
that happened during the guacamaya the
guacamaya leagues you're now seeing that
Mexico has been hosting members of the
Haitian military and they've been
training them up to go back to police
their country
that's not something that Mexico has
been known for to hosting other nations
and and training them in such a way so
it's like a it's a it's an interesting
maneuver like Mexico has been
historically neutral about getting
involved in foreign conflicts about
voting and resolutions as far as
invading or not invading or doing all
these things
Mexico has been historically kind of
neutral when it comes to some of these
things and now we're training foreign
military forces to go and do that role
somewhere else
we have the military building airports
and building infrastructure in Mexico
when a lot of their higher ups getting
very you know wealthy around it you know
and they basically have a monopoly over
you know who gets to have guns down
there you know there's one gun store in
all Mexico and it's run by the military
and the only way you can buy a gun there
is if you can buy a plane ticket to fly
there and have enough money to sustain
that uh that right or that privilege
So you you're seeing the military not
being in its traditional role of just
being the security Force now it's
policing it's involved in it's it's
getting involved in politics in a big
way you know it's uh the legislation
that has passed to keep it on the
streets and the policing role for more
years now so
that should be looked at Closer by
anybody observing it uh from afar how
the militarization of Mexico and where
it's going because if you move towards a
world where a world war three happens it
feels like Mexico will be the center
because
a hot War would be fought on the ground
and so you have a very difficult
parallel between Mexico and Ukraine both
don't have nuclear weapons both have
relationships so Ukraine has a
relationship or a pull towards the
European Union and NATO
Mexico at least currently has a kind of
slow pull towards China India
potentially and Russia and you have this
divide between power centers in the
world
and in terms of just imagine
hundreds of thousands of Mexican troops
hundreds of thousands of Chinese troops
on the border
on the U.S border yeah on the Mexican
side and also the fact that that border
doesn't mean anything to any sort of
conflict that would happen regionally
because that that's a very easy to
cross-border doesn't matter how many
walls you put across it people are
already here uh this is not going to be
a war fought off in some overseas place
like you're not gonna this is something
if if it happens if destabilization is
utilized in Mexico
to cause a conflict there and it turns
into a Vietnam or a proxy war down there
of a sword which I think
in a way you're already kind of seeing
some of that uh through some of the
conflicts going on down there you have a
a new generation cartel that is being
fed fentanyl from the Pacific side ports
and
and suspiciously you know you you want
to think that maybe it's favored by a
foreign government of some sort uh in
some way shape or form uh who knows and
then you have a historically in control
seen in law cartel that Miron may not be
favored by the U.S in some way shape or
form you can imagine a further conflict
down there and people fostering it and
seeing the effects of basically setting
a fire on the feet of the United States
its second largest consumer of U.S
products is Mexico
um the massive wave of immigration that
is going to be basically weaponized uh
you know you saw the collapse of the
border security structure with the
contingent of 3 000 Honduran Guatemalan
immigrants in that first the wave of
Caravans coming to Tijuana you saw it
was it was pretty bad you know
it was pretty bad and it could have
gotten worse
now what is going to happen when that
wave is no not no longer 3000 but you
know a million people being displaced by
violence or being
in fear of whatever conflict might
originate down there and just that
massive wave of migration and move like
I think that's a that's an interesting
thing that people should look at and you
know how can you affect change to try
and stop some of the these things that
happen